can you take me back do you remember
when you first met take off and Amigos
because you guys literally came into the
game together you were forever be
synonymous with each other's careers
um
yeah I think it was amount of time I had
I did a song with
um cash out from Atlanta and then I was
on the way to a show not from I ain't
really had no shows but I was on the way
to somebody else's show to go watch a
performance and they were like the whole
club ride I mean the whole car ride one
of my homies Peewee he was playing
nothing but the Migos tape
and I was like yo what if I could like
don't think it's just walking right it's
going crazy
and he like um the Migos they're from
the north side whatever like yeah I'll
get you over there and whatever I was
like cool whatever so the next day
I had I had took the CD from him so the
next day there's like a phone number on
the end of the city it's like DJ Ray G
who was there DJ time I caught him like
yo where G I knew a g I'm like yo you
[__] with the Migos I'm trying to get up
with them [__] them [__] is hard he
like hell yeah we're gonna get in the
studio whatever yeah I was like bet so
that same night
it was like it's like a club in Atlanta
that used to be popping it's called
Mansion alone of course I went to that
club and then randomly I seen Ray G
outside the front of the club with the
Migos and he like yo this is the video
I'm talking about I'm saying we're gonna
link up and then we connected that night
and then like
two days later I went over to cuevos and
we just did history yeah like locked in
pretty much that's it that's crazy man